today eurasia Ben Russell is gonna show
me something that Victorians might have
got up to in their equivalent of your
garden shed in another story food stalls
these look incredible and they look 3d
printed to me but I'm guessing a little
bit before 3d printing if you're a
mechanically minded chap or organ
actually and you wanted to play with
machines before the car came along you'd
have a lathe you have been laid like
this and this is just the base of the
bare bones in the machine so worried
heavy to have a chuck here which holds a
piece of material like ivy or boxwood or
something like that
and then as you rotated it here you've
got a treadle here so like a Singer
sewing machine you have treadle away and
that would turn the piece there was a
cutting tool here which would cut into
it and what they're doing is they're
producing remarkable decorative pieces
like this pick this up you think about
because a little bit strange but then
you turn it through 90 degrees new
realize it's a tube of Wellington which
is really quite smashing what so is this
all carved from one continuous pieces
actually what it's not always that this
would be all would be fossil ivory no
issue there because the fossil IV would
have been laying around on the floor for
millennia with elephants so it just dies
and so basically you would be producing
little tiny parts of these which would
have it very sort of strip together some
of the parts are quite bigger than you
get some of these little tiny decorative
bits like these so the idea is you would
buy the lathe and you would buy the
attachments we have the manual
absolutely so here we have Holtz that
falls turning in botanical relation to
volume 5 there's a sixth wall in which
they never planned and what you have
here this is all your guidebook to your
you know your your world of mechanical
wonders in or mental turning and and as
you can see once you start opening you
have these worked examples which I
produce a lot you know if you can do
this too so is this the sort of thing
that someone would have in their shed
yes in a way this is the proto shed some
places you go and hide away from your
family and have a smoke and pour some
alcohol and and and then do that sort of
thing so so people with these would have
a workshop and you go away and you
produce Turney and very often these
pieces you know they're designed to be
shown off you know you're showing your
skin as a turn about producing a piece
like this and you would have it and you
would display and your drawing room or
living
you